Folks we are certainly in the dog days of summer. It is going to be a hot hot HOTTIE
That will be $3.75.
Uh. Keep the change, this is $1.00 ah here you look.. beau..beau
Charlie!
Large pepperoni.
No offense, but is your dog pregnant or just super fat? I called you for pizza. Not opinions.
This is why kids don't like old people.
He's lethargic. His appetite is down. Sam needs to get out there and meet some new dogs. That'll be $300.
I found her yesterday.
Her little face looks so angry and happy at the same time.
Pregnancy has changed your sister. Move away from the door. She has the rage of a chimp.
You keep my dog alive until I get back from the hospital.
My building has a strict no-dog policy. So I'll get evicted.
How am I gonna get you up there?
Oh, come on in!
Would it be possible to like volunteer?
Yes
Mr. Pepperoni!
Mabel, Mabel!
You lost, pumpkin?
Can we keep her? Ohh
Joining us today is a former L.A ram.
A co-host? He's a tackler he doesn't know anything about hosting a morning news show. Woah!
The audience loves you two together.
Charlie, every spot you've sniffed on this walk is the same. Just pee anywhere!
I want to help you find your dog.
You should be my best friend.
This dog has made us a family
Whose dog is that?
Britney!
I almost don't recognize you without steam coming out to your ears.
Our landlord just sold the building out from under us. What about a fundraiser?
We're at the new tricks charity event. So, come on down.
You know what? I'm going to run. Five stars!
Dogs open their hearts to us to love and to be loved and I find that beautiful.
Oh, that's just my equipment. Let them out! Whatever you think is happening is not.. Let them out! It's a dog!
Oh, hi puppy!